men are in crisis men splaining men
spreading mayonnaise times up Woody
Allen Dave Navarro we've got a lot of
issues guys thankfully I'm here to help
now why am i qualified cuz I've got a
popular podcast a gender-neutral haircut
and I've dealt with every problem that a
man can have I've got a rectal
dysfunction right now I'm Theo von and
this is man up
[Music]
[Applause]
so this week's episode is about growth
and I got a call from kalila who is a
girlfriend of an old friend of mine
named Bobby Lee or Bob Lee and some of
you guys have seen him and he hasn't
really exhibited growth very well in his
life so first things first I went over
there to help out he's the absolute love
of my life I don't see a future without
him but there are some barriers to our
relationship namely my stepdad my
stepdads a little bit more traditional
and he has some concerns say if I were a
peeping tom right and you're not here
and I show up cuz I got a ladder I got
everything I need right I got the gloves
I got a thermos you know I got time to
kill you know I'm unemployed and I'm
here watching in through the windows and
I see Bobby what is he gonna be doing
what am I gonna see him doing 16 hours
of video game play with the occasional
intermittent break of masturbatory
activities Jesus Christ mm-hmm I know
when I see somebody that needs to evolve
a little bit right and for me it just
seems like Bobby just wants to play this
child forever he's a man baby he's a man
baby when I first moved in here I would
walk out to the balcony and I would
always get this strong smell of ammonia
then I see this massive jug of yellow
fluid mm-hmm so I ask them Bobby what is
that this natural urine isn't it it's
natural urine that's an easy one he says
it's a Korean thing I don't buy it
yeah I'm by that either I watched a lot
of Korean online I've never seen
anything like that
and I used to pee and my girlfriend's
sink at night and the cats would show up
and they started peeing in there and
that's how her mom knew that I was
peeing in there so it's uh you know it's
oh there's a lot of ways to get caught
up in that let me give you an example of
my stepdad 70th birthday okay six people
in the table fancy dinner I asked Bobby
hey no gadgets so you didn't know what
to do with his hands so naturally his
hands found my breasts oh wow
during dinner
stewardess breath mostly breasts mostly
waist up did he witness some of it he
witnessed all of it he's a dude that
makes my neck hurt
that 70th birthday fiasco is what I want
to erase out of everyone's memory right
so I want to have a dinner with my
stepdad I want to redo yes I got a good
idea if you don't mind I'd like to maybe
take him aside for a little bit and see
if we can't you know do some things
crack into that jaundice phenomenon
that's going on beyond his eyes and see
what we can create please okay look I
can relate
Bobby has extra urine around the house
I've been there you know I've done a lot
of poor choices I got two bags of body
hair under my sink right now one of them
is mine but I know that I have to change
the mission now was getting Bobby to
know that he needs to change as well Bob
he has nothing crazy let's do what is
this I'm just hanging out man seen if
you were home yeah I am home yeah you
weren't home okay what's going on man
hey good to see you bro yeah you look
good just like a little she's gonna be
like kind of like an intervention but
nobody nobody's here sub us the
intervention I've been sober for like 15
years so I'm good
it's not about that though right she's
good nobody's pregnant let's go outside
that's all right yeah bro we're not
being crazy I promise I mean some people
would've raised you but we're not them
you don't gonna call me and tell me
about 80 feet it looks like dude just
call me and tell me that you know that
you're gonna do this then what I mean
you're bad is this like just cause I'm
saying I feel bad now yeah but there's a
crew my house weird oh come on first of
all kalila reached out to me okay I'm
not trying to be rude but what he called
you she said something to me on the
phone she called a weird
she said straight fine well she that's
not exactly how she framed it yeah but
how did she frame it I'll say Bobby
masturbates around the house different
places urinates outdoors and dude as
people live out here neighbors man yeah
I'm also is at a school oh can I say
this though yes defend myself all right
in society we make these rules like
etiquette okay right but these rules are
meant to be broken
yeah in high school Bobby in junior high
you know in kindergarten and pre-k
people off the balcony and you
know pissing in front of people there's
60 people live over all right so I'm
just saying let's try this bro
we go to this thing today with me and
then we go to another event with this
family and we see if you can step it up
bro she's already down over a second I
gotta go places with you all right
she's already down over a second - I'm
putting me next time no seriously next
time yeah you call me and you tell me
that you're gonna do this because it's
okay is your phone on I
try to text you notice along because of
my Southern roots I know that manners
are important and what Bob a bear here
is missing is a little bit of him man
wash so I took a little Bobby to a
cotillion class with some high society
[Music]
say hello everyone to our get oh we're
going in for a hug okay
Harleen I actually went for that because
I didn't want to be rude but that we're
gonna work on it this time no it has
nothing to do with uh Smith Nissa T I'm
an all-inclusive person I just went in
like a little too hot oven you went in
like we a little too familiar I would
say we are all here to actually teach
you some manners today I know all the
matters but all right well I'm here to
teach you all the things that you don't
know that you don't know like if I lived
in England in a castle no this is
actually what I like to call real life
skills these are everyday courtesies
that you should know and anyone should
know for both your personal and your
professional life okay that's we're
gonna work on that no that's not
happening anytime you make some
you need to know the proper greeting we
want to have one arms-length of distance
which is about 18 inches between you and
another person we are not going to flap
our wings like a birdie we're gonna
pretend we have books on either side of
our waist and we are going to act as if
we are conducting an orchestra see here
we go here we go stop stop stop I made
all these arrangements for Bobby to take
a moment to not think about himself and
to listen to somebody else and actually
display a little bit of congeniality I
swear to god I've heard it twice already
but it was quiet in America we are told
to chew Hawaiian Ling radical I didn't
know that yeah well I think our last
hope is if Bobby can properly know how
to make a toast otherwise I don't even
see how he's gonna survive this tomorrow
you don't think you're not placing good
bet sighs you want me to do a toast here
here here here I would like to salute
way excuse me I have to interrupt you
open with the lines I would like to
propose a toast
here here is at the end of the toast
let's try it again you're laughing but
this is serious business this is the
worst human experience I've ever had in
my life yeah how does that make me feel
no I think you're great feel so badly
not funny guys so things hadn't gone
well the big dinner had arrived and I
realized that Bobby was gonna need some
assistance hello how you doing you all
right yeah I'm fine
you don't always pull out my chair I
know because I'm a different man my
forms start I called the both of you to
have dinner because the last dinner that
we had together didn't go so well when
we go out to eat yeah you are constantly
groping her in front of everyone
because you see something no just wait a
second let me just hear this out when
you do this it's kind of insulting all
right okay that's good I understand that
good evening guys my name is Chucky
I'll be your children's evening Chucky
hey Chucky
nice to see you Hey oh just the three of
you guys tonight awesome
welcome to the district have anybody
told you about our specials not yet no
no you're the first guy to say hi
excellent tonight we have a 7 ounce duck
yeah that's it that's gonna be it yeah
we have ones what's on the duck comes
natural the duck comes in its own sauce
and it's what kind of sauce is it I can
ask the chef for you sir we should know
that right as a waiter I'm new here sir
okay all right thank you very much
thanks man I know it's I'm just gonna
see my girls are pretty it's all right
okay suck it in suck it suck it in a
little
I need your belly to go down a bit okay
there we go
I knew that Bobby might need some help
so I slipped him an earpiece here-here
Kawana kalila Roger Roger
nothing you both of you I am grateful to
have your mind I'm grateful to have you
in my life
kalila kalila you are mine you are my
Native American middle-earth a Native
American loves us sir
we're not Native American you look like
Pocahontas right now though and that's
what you don't want saying you know
exactly what I'm saying
I don't let me start over let me start
over
come on uncle ila I just want to say I'm
sorry I just want to say I'm sorry
because I spend a lot of time because I
spend a lot of time thinking about
myself thinking about myself you were my
angel
well you are my angel your face and you
are special you're special to me and I
am so happy to have your mom I'm so
happy to have you in my life thank you
sweetie
and I'm very grateful to Roger and I'm
grateful to Roger because just like me
because just like me he recognizes
amazing women when he sees that he
recognizes a basic woman when he sees
them even though he's dating your mom
and not Jim even though you're dating
her mom and not her you know what I mean
you know what I mean look I love you
here here here here
everyone says here here everyone here
what I learned from watching Bobby is
that you have to take your problems
seriously you have to step into the
situation and you have to do it you have
to do the work there Bobby do the work
today no I don't think he did but he at
least showed up and hopefully you show
up you show up you show up and then
sometime you feel comfortable enough to
man up and maybe next week we will will
have a different outcome but thank you
guys for being here with me I'm Theo von
and this has been manna